Hi.
I'm Dan Lavelle from the Google
Play Developer Operations team.
We get a lot of questions from
developers about app visibility
and search on Google Play.
While we can't reveal every
ingredient in the secret sauce,
I want to cover some tips
to set you up for success.
The first thing you should do is
double-check your configuration
to make sure your app is
visible to the right audience.
If it's your first
time publishing,
verify that your app is
published, not in draft,
and that it's available
on the Production track
and not just alpha or beta.
If you previously
pushed your APK
to the alpha or beta
tracks, click on that track.
Then click the
Move to Prod button
under Actions for
the version that you
want to push to production.
Remember, it may
take a few hours
to see your changes
appear on Google Play.
Next, check your app's
pricing and distribution page
to make sure you've targeted
all the countries that you
want to distribute to.
Click Show Options to verify you
haven't restricted distribution
to any particular
wireless carrier.
Lastly, you want to determine if
your configuration is excluding
any devices.
For the APK page under
Supported Devices,
click See List to view the
Device Compatibility list.
By default, you'll
see supported devices.
But you can also filter
the list to see devices
that are unsupported by your
configuration or devices you've
manually excluded.
If your app isn't showing
up in search results
for a specific device, consider
its feature requirements.
You can see a summary
of APK details
by clicking on your
APK version number.
The API level, screen layout,
resolution, and other feature
requirements can often exclude
a user's device automatically.
For example, if you app's
minimum API level is 16-plus,
only uses of Jelly
Bean and above
will see your app
in search results
when searching Google
Play on their device.
Get as much information
as possible from the user
when looking into
compatibility issues,
and make sure you're not
unintentionally excluding
that device due to your
app's feature requirements.
It may seem like a no-brainer
to create a solid app
title and description,
but you want
to make sure that your title
is focused, unique, and avoids
too many common words.
Your description
should be thorough.
However, the full
text will likely
be truncated under
a Read More button,
so include what's
most attractive
and valuable to
users above the fold.
Also remember to follow
Google Play content policies
when creating your
store listing.
Getting more data
about user behavior
can be critical to
improving your apps.
You can integrate Mobile App
Analytics from Google Analytics
to get insight
about user behavior,
set up custom campaigns
to judge the effectiveness
of external marketing
campaigns, and get a better
understanding of your audience.
Lastly and most importantly,
you should aim to deliver a high
quality and lasting
experience for users,
deliver regular
updates for your app,
and encourage users to provide
feedback and +1 recommendations
on Google Play.
Remember to respond to customers
that have had a bad experience.
It could be the difference in
turning a 1 star review into 5.
Hopefully some of these tips
help you reach even more users.
But you can always learn more
at the Google Play Android
Developer Help Center.
Until next time,
I'm Dan Lavelle,
and this has been Play.Bytes.